c'est ce qu'on appelle du paintball
sportif avec des balles à 350 kilomètres
heure ramper dans la boue et parfois
vital ça fait un peu mal comme comme ici
la bo maintenant je le sens même plus
quoi
ici les joueurs sont professionnels ou
semi-professionnels
il se prépare comme des athlètes de haut
niveau
les gars savent bury à gauche il ya une
grosse adrénaline faut pas se leurrer la
bille quand elle touche épique dont on
sait pertinemment quand ça tape ça va
venir nous piquer et cette adrénaline la
fois les c'est ça qui fait qu'on compte
se surpassent je pense que même des
personnes six maîtres à jouer à ça il
vous sort découvrir un élément essentiel
de l'équipement du joueur le lanceur en
france il est considéré comme une arme
si vous avez une réserve d'air pour
propulser la vie ici vous avez une
réserve de billes qu'on appelle le
loader et le canon qui sert à guider
dhabi ensuite on a des po où on a des
billes à l'intérieur qui permettent tout
simplement de recharger le loader en
cours de partie
donc quand on a la technique on louvre à
une main et on vient relever et on peut
continuer à jouer
chris est l'une des rares femmes sur le
terrain
attention c'est un sort dur il faut être
en bonne condition physique ça peut
faire mal
je pense que c'est pour ça que beaucoup
de femmes arrêtent
après avoir essayé plus de 20 pays sont
représentés au championnat